how does sleep affect learning
sleep
before learning sleep after learning
which are both fascinating kind of
dynamics
of the mind's interaction with this
extra conscious state
yeah sleep is
profoundly
and very intimately related to your
memory systems and your informational
systems
the first as you just mentioned is that
sleep before learning will essentially
prepare your brain um almost like a dry
sponge ready to sort of
you know initially soak up new
information in other words you need
sleep before learning to effectively
imprint information into the brain to
lay down fresh memory traces
and without sleep the memory circuits of
the brain and we know we've studied
these memory circuits
it will
you know essentially become waterlogged
as it were for the sponge analogy and
you can't absorb
the information as effectively
so you need sleep before learning but
you also need sleep unfortunately after
learning two
to then take those freshly minted
memories and effectively hit the save
button on them but it's nowhere near as
quick as a digital system it takes hours
because it's a physical biological
change that happens at the level of
brain cells but sleep after learning
will cement and solidify that
new memory into the neural architecture
of the brain therefore making it less
likely to be forgotten
so
you know i often think of sleep in that
way as
it's almost sort of future proofing
information
in in what way well it means that it
gives it a higher degree of assurance
to be remembered in the future rather
than go through
the
sort of degradation that we think of as
forgetting
so
the brain has
in some ways by default you know
there is forget and actually i would
love to
i was going to say sleep is relevant for
memory in three different ways but i'm
going to amend that and say there's four
different ways
which is learning
maintaining memorizing
abstraction assimilation association
and then forgetting which
the last one sounds oxymoronic based on
the form of three but i'll see if i can
explain
so sleep after learning then sort of you
know
sets the that information like amber
um in you know in solidification
the third benefit however is that sleep
we've learned more recently is much more
intelligent than we ever gave it credit
for
sleep doesn't simply just take
individual memories
and strengthen them
sleep will then
intelligently integrate and cross link
and associate that information together
and it's almost like informational
alchemy
so that you wake up the next morning
with a revised mind wide web of
associations
and that's probably the reason that you
know you've never been told to stay
awake on a problem
you know
and
in every language that i've inquired
about that phrase or very something very
similar seems to exist which means to me
that
this creative associative benefit of
sleep transcends cultural boundaries it
is a common experience across humanity
now i should note that i think the
french translation of that is much
closer to you um i think you sleep with
a problem whereas the british you know
you sleep on a problem the french you
sleep with a problem i think it says so
much about the romantic difference
between the british and the french but
let's let's not go there um that's
brilliant so such a subtle but such a
fundamental difference yeah
yeah goodness maybe sleep with the
problem yes exactly
um
so
and we can just double click on any one
of these uh and go in into detail but
the fourth i became really enchanted by
about
eight years ago in our research which
was this idea of
forgetting and i started to
think that forgetting maybe the price
that we pay for remembering
and in that sense
there is an enormous
benefit
to letting go
and you may be thinking that sounds
ridiculous i don't want to forget in
fact my biggest problem is i keep
forgetting things
but
the brain
it has a fi well we believe has a finite
storage capacity we can't prove it yet
but my suspicion is that that's probably
true it doesn't have an infinite storage
capacity it has constraints
if that's the case we can't simply go
through life being you know
constantly informational aggregators
unless you know we are programmed to say
we've got a hard drive space of about 85
to 90 years and we're good and we can do
that maybe that's true i don't think
that's true i think forgetting is an
incredibly good and useful thing so for
example you know
it's not beneficial from an evolutionary
perspective for me to remember where i
parked my car three years ago
so it's important that i can remember
today's parking spot but i don't want to
have the junk
kind of dna from a memory perspective of
you know where my i parked my car you
know two years ago um
now i actually have a in some ways a
problem with forgetting i'm and again
i'm not trying to sort of be laudatory
but
you know i i tend not to forget too many
things and i don't think that that's a
good thing
and um the there's a wonderful um
neurologist laurea who wrote a book
called the mind of the mnemonicist and
it was a brilliant book
both because it was written exquisitely
but he was studying
these sort of memory savants
who basically could remember everything
that he gave them
and he tried to find
a [ __ ] in their armor
and the first half of the book is
essentially about him
seeing how far he can push them before
they fail
and he never found that place
he could never find a place where they
stopped
remembering and then in his brilliance
he turned the question on its head he
said not what is the benefit of
constantly remembering
but instead what is the detriment
to never forgetting and when you start
to realize his descriptions of those
individuals it's probably a life that
you would not want
but it's fascinating both from a human
perspective but also ai perspective
there's a
there's a big challenge in the machine
learning community of how to build
systems that are able to remember for
prolonged periods of time
lifelong continuous learning so where
you build up
information over time so memory is one
of the biggest open problems in uh
in ai and machine learning but at the
same time the right way to formulate
memory
is actually forgetting
because
you have to be exceptionally selective
at which kind of stuff you remember and
that's where the step of a simulation
integration that you're referring to is
really important i mean we forget most
of the things and and the question is
exactly the cost of forgetting
at the very edge of stuff that could be
important or could not be
how do we remember not those things like
for example
i've uh you know doing a podcast i've
become
cognizant of one feature of my
forgetting that's been problematic
which is i forget
names and titles of books and so on so
when i read
i remember ideas
i remember quotes
i remember statements and like that's
the space in which i'm thinking
but when you communicate to others
you have to say this person in this book
said that
it's the same thing with uh like andrew
huberman is masterful at this this is
important academia remembering the
authors of a paper and the title of the
paper
as part of remembering the idea
and i've been feeling the cost of not
not being able to naturally remember
those things and so that that's
something i need to sort of work on but
that's an example with faces
yes very good at faces but not good with
names so i am exactly like
you and there is you know an
understanding of that in the brain too
we understand that there is partitioning
of those in terms of the territory of
the brain that takes care of faces and
facts and places and that they can be
separate so i will never forget
face but you know and as i said i
usually forget very little but for some
reason names are
a struggle i think in some ways because
i'm probably just a slightly anxious
person so when you first meet someone
which is usually the time when a name is
introduced you know you were saying you
were sort of anxious maybe about sort of
sitting down with me um but
i find that a little bit
you know activating and so
it's not as though there's anything
wrong with my memory it's just
the emotional state i'm in when i'm
first meeting someone yeah you know it's
a little bit perturbing but i will never
forget the face but um i completely
relate to that because i almost don't
hear uh people's names when they tell me
because i'm so anxious yeah yeah
but i i think there's certain quirks of
social interaction
that uh show that you care about the
person that you remember that person
that they mattered to you they had an
impact on you and one of the ways to
show that is you remember their name and
but that's a quirk to me because there's
a lot of people i me
have a deep impact on me
but
they i can't communicate that unless i
know their name unless i know some of
the um
details that
that we humans seem to use to
communicate that will remember each
other what i i remember well
is the feeling we shared
is the experience was shared
what i don't remember well is the
detailed labels of of those experiences
and i need to certainly work on that i i
don't know i think it's you know just
allowing yourself to be innate and who
you are is also a beautiful thing too
i'm not suggesting it's not important to
try and better oneself and
but i also sometimes worry about the
misery that that puts us in but
like you i will
i i do struggle with name but
i know for the first time when we met in
the lobby
um i know exactly
what you look like i know that you were
wearing headphones i know the shape and
the size of those headphones you didn't
have your black jacket on i know exactly
what the weave of your shirt looked like
and you know what your shoes look like
and i knew exactly the height of your
the end of your pants from the top of
your shoes yeah and so those things i
don't forget you know and i can that's
fascinating remember when people i met
people you know two years ago and i'll
say oh yes we met there and um i
remember you had those fantastic you
know boots on i thought they were pretty
great pair of boots you know like how do
you i didn't even remember what i was
wearing that day yeah it's fascinating
yeah i'm exactly the same way but you
can't
until we have neurolink or something
like that we can't communicate that you
remember all those things i know that's
what i wanted so you have to be able to
use tricks of human communication for
that but so that i mean that's the it
ultimately is a trick of like which to
remember which to forget right and the
forgetting is so it's so fascinating to
say this i mean it seems to be
deeply connected to that assimilation
process so forgetting you try to fit
all the new stuff into
this big web of the old stuff
and the things that don't fit you throw
out
i think the assimilation the way i've
been thinking about it with sleep and
it's particularly sort of dream sleep
that we think can help with this
assimilation
is that
during wake we have one version of
associative processing what i mean by
that is we see the most obvious
connections
so i think of wakefulness
as a google search gone right
whereas i see dream sleep as doing
something very different i think dream
sleep is a little bit like group therapy
for memories
that everyone gets a name badge
and sleep gathers in all of the
individual pieces of the day and it sort
of starts to get you to forces you in
fact to speak to the people not at the
front of the room that you think you've
got the most obvious connection with but
to speak with the people all the way at
the back of the room that at first you
think i've got no obvious connection
with them at all but once you get
chatting with them
you learn that you do have a very
distant non-obvious connection but it's
still a connection not the same
and it's almost as though you're doing a
google search where you know i input you
know lex friedman and
it doesn't take me to the first page of
your home site h20 takes me to page 20
which is about some like field hockey
game in utah yeah exactly it turns out
that there actually is a link if i look
at it yeah distant non-obvious one and
to me i find that exciting because when
you fuse things together that shouldn't
normally go together but when they do
they cause marked advances in
evolutionary fitness it sounds like the
biological basis of creativity
and that's exactly what i think dream
sleep and the algorithm of dream sleep
is designed to do
you know it's not a boolean like system
where you have you know the sort of
assumptions of true and false you know
maybe it's more fuzzy logic system and i
think rem sleep is a perfect environment
within which we do you know it's almost
like memory pinball you know you get the
information that you've learned during
the day
and then you pull the lever back and you
shoot it up into the attic of your brain
you know this cortex filled with all of
your past historical knowledge and you
start to bounce it around and see where
one of those things lights up and you
build a new connection there and you
build another one there too you're
developing schemas
and so in that way i think you could
argue
you know we dream therefore we are
you